you
[Music]
good morning everyone thank you all for
coming and thanks everyone on the stream
for watching it's my pleasure to welcome
dr. Hema yoga Narasimhan from to
visitors today she is a professor in the
foster School of Business at University
of Washington and her work focuses on
combining machine learning and
statistical econometrics methods to
address problems in the domain of
marketing and online platforms she
received her PhD MA and MPhil in
marketing and business from Yale prior
to that she received her bachelor's at
IIT Madras and she has been at u-dub
since 2014 she has won many many awards
but since we are starting late let's
just get right into the talk looking
forward thanks Emma thank you thank you
so much for hosting me and thank you all
of you for coming and thanks also to the
people watching so today I wanted to
talk a little bit about some of the work
that have been doing recently in the
domain of targeting and you know how it
kind of intersects with these questions
related to privacy especially in the
context of mobile advertising and this
is a joint work with my student or my
ruffian who is also in the foster School
of Business so let me start by giving
you a little bit of background about
mobile adoption and usage this you know
doesn't really need a slide but you know
just to give you some numbers so
smartphones as we all know are
increasingly popular there are two
billion smartphone users worldwide and
this statistic when I first saw it kind
of shocked me the average user spends
about 3.3 hours a day on their phone and
what's kind of interesting is the bulk
of this usage actually comes through
apps that isn't most desktop devices you
know the bulk of the use it happens
through browsers here it mostly comes
through apps and in 2016 our internet
usage by are like you know mobile
devices with smartphones and tablets
exceeded Internet usage by desktops for
the first time obviously where their
eyeballs are that's where the
advertisers want to be so there has been
seen a concurrent increase in the
you know growth of mobile advertising so
now the worldwide revenue you know
exceeds 183 billion dollars predicted to
exceed 200 billion and what's really
interesting is that now it's actually
constitutes the largest share of digital
total digital ad spend compared to like
you know other forms of digital you know
advertising so and the bulk of this you
know advertising revenue is I tribute it
to a kind of a unique type of ad with
advertising format which is kind of
unique to mobile devices which is in-app
advertising so so what's an in-app ad
essentially you know when you're using
any app you see these like little banner
ads in the bottom so those are in-app
ads and in-app ads have become popular
because from you know both from you know
publishers perspective or apps
perspective and like advertisers
perspective they're nice from a
publishers perspective there are a
common app monetization strategy in the
sense that you know you I built an app I
want to make money I could either sell
the app or I could monetize the app by
you know showing ads so so that's why
publishers like them the ad industry
kinda likes them because they have some
properties which are very unique to
mobile devices in particular there is
something called the IDF a in Apple
iPhones or Android ID a ID in Android
devices and this is the ID which is
unique to every mobile device which
cannot be reset sorry which can actually
which which which is very persistent and
it's until and until it's actually
actively reset by the user I think
before 2012 or so there was no way to
even actively reset it so you know your
data was there forever and it was linked
to your ID now you can actually go and
reset it you can reset your you know ID
FA or a ID but what this really means is
that most AG networks and platforms now
because this is actually tied to your
device ID they are able to do excellent
user tracking much better than what you
can do on desktop for instance or even
on like browsers mobile browsers because
they can stitch together all this
data across sessions and apps and ads
and really get this global view of like
how this user is interacting with apps
and ads across many things so while this
is in some ways great from the
perspective or from the ad industry or
advertisers this is raised a bunch of
concerns from you know both regulators
as well as consumer privacy advocates
because on the one hand what you might
think of this is like better tracking
especially behavioral tracking because
you have this user ID on one hand
increases efficiency in the market what
you know you know you if you know what
kind of an ad user is going to click on
for instance you're going to maybe be
able to serve them more relevant ads
which they might click on so you know it
increases maybe efficiency in the market
but at the same time it has also left
all these concerns about privacy like
you know this extent of ability to track
users especially in a persistent way
whenever I give this talk I usually ask
this question of how many of you have
reset your IDs like yeah so it's it's
one person just now haha that was fast
so you know most people haven't and you
know it's not like cookies which people
are kind of aware off and clear
regularly so this takes much longer to
do and so you know so so this kind of
like this debate between like you know
what is the right level of targeting and
how you know what is how does this
interact or interfere with like privacy
privacy related questions and this was
part of it is like in a specific to the
mobile setting but as part of this
broader debate over consumer tracking
and privacy which is kind of happening
now and if you really think about there
many different stakeholders or players
here on one hand we have advertisers who
want fewer protections and more
behavioral tracking tools there are
consumers who want higher privacy and
limits on targeting at the same time
they also want free products which you
know which are supported which you know
to support which you need kind of
advertising and there are also
regulators and Garmin for example GDP
are by EU which was quite which kicked
in
like me and what they're trying to do is
kind of kind of balance this
profitability motives with consumer
protection and the key question which is
kind of you know underlying all this is
for example the ad industry wants to
self-regulate rather than have external
regulation imposed on them the question
is to what extent is self regulation
even feasible to what extent so there
are these different types of players to
what extent are there incentives in any
way aligned right and this question of
like you know to what extent is
self-regulation feasible is
fundamentally if you think about it more
conceptually it's related to this
question of or this idea of revenue
efficiency trade-off in which has been
you know which we have known or thought
about in the auction's literature for a
long period of time and the idea here so
think about targeting is increasing
efficiency when I can target better I
can show more relevant tax to some
people I make the system more efficient
right but what we know is or what what
you can think of as like higher
efficiency does not really lead to
higher revenues so the intuition here is
that if you have fat-tailed
distributions of you know advertisers
valuations for impressions and market
are same then when you have to contract
efficiently this means that you're going
to pay a higher informational rent to
the advertiser so you might increase the
pie by actually targeting but
advertisers are going to extract most of
the surplus and therefore you as the
platform or the ad network might not
actually be able to you know increase
your revenue and this was in particular
in the case of online ad auctions so 11
and Milgrim in 2010 had this kind of now
well-known paper where they conjectured
that narrow targeting which means like
more and more targeting where you have
these like narrow groups or like where
you're targeting on can actually create
thin markets what they meant by thin
markets is that the number of people
that you're actually increasing the
heterogeneity in the evaluation of
people for the same person now so I
think of you all as one homogenous one
group then I have some expected value
but now if I can identify each of you
individually
different advertisers valuation for each
of you is going to become more and more
heterogeneous maybe a bunch of people
decide these four people are not
relevant only one person is relevant you
know so now this becomes a thin market
so that's kind of the idea and I'll get
into the you know the theory of this
more later but the whole entire idea was
that more efficiency does not lead to
more revenue intuitively and that was
kind of their intuition and and and that
you know so that's what might happen so
since that happened since they kind of
conjectured there were a bunch of
theoretical papers written to show that
this might be the case under some
distribution of valuations however what
no one could kind of prove was that and
particularly this happens like okay so
this is like a theoretical you can show
in theory it could happen but you know
does it really happen just do real
platforms or can we are targeting
actually hit those levels where revenue
starts going down and you can see that
this relates to the question this kind
of ties back to this question of privacy
because if from a platforms perspective
you know more and more targeting is not
always beneficial then you can imagine
that the platform might actually have
incentives to limit targeting which
means that they might have some
incentive to preserve users privacy at
least to some level not totally but at
least to some level right and that's
where you know if that's the case then
that then maybe this self regulation is
a feasibility from a policy perspective
yes I don't think I immediately
understand why more targeting or having
creatives in our markets actually leads
to higher efficiency I'm just thinking
about like our broadband system right
where you have like some companies that
have just targeted certain areas and
they are the default and other companies
or the default elsewhere so you know
Comcast and Verizon are not actually
going to compete for your internet allah
comcast will or this region whereas in
cars of that region say then you
essentially i don't see that it leads to
an efficient market either okay so
efficiency here means that there are
let's say that are certified with isis
competing on an impression so an
efficient allocation would be that the
you are the
vacation is being made to the advertiser
who creates the overall maximum surplus
so it's like the most relevant ad which
is being shown and I will so this is
maybe either in the later in the talk I
have a slide where I have an example and
then a theoretical formulation of that
so maybe that will help but the
intuition is the basic intuition is that
if if I know for example there is
someone here is one person everyone's
well on average let's say valued at $10
like for an advertiser
but now I can give you more and more
information about each person then I
realize you are valuable for advertiser
a at like hundred dollars and the next
person is valuable at like for the next
advertiser B you're valuable at like $1
now you have created this heterogeneity
in valuation by giving more information
so you your impression now for sure will
be matched with the hundred dollar
advertiser but then because it's
efficient contracting mechanism all
auctions you know tend to move being
that in that kind of sphere then you the
advertiser a wins this wins your
impression $400 but actually pays $1 and
so you created this $100 expected value
but the platform gets $1 and advertiser
gets $99 that's why you know maybe the
revenue the surplus increase but the
revenue for the platform dent yes
relative value versus cost of delivering
an ad to someone who is likely to be
receptive to that ad versus the cost of
delivering an ad to someone who wouldn't
be receptive to it so the cost of so the
cost here is mainly going to come from
the opportunity cost so in the sense
that let's say that ad was most relevant
to you but I ended up delivering to
other now there's going to be a
difference and maybe the response rates
and that is where the cost is
intuitively going to come from I don't
think I captured for instance you know
you were shown an irrelevant ad that
does does does that somehow make you
upset or like not use the platform or
something so that is not taken into
account so if you so the or rather
normalized to zero yeah okay so so the
so the research agenda for this paper in
some ways has like three broad goals so
the first is we want to think about this
question of targeting and efficiencies
so if you're in Ag Network how do you
develop targeting policies right so you
have some data then how do you decide
what are the ways in which you can do
develop different targeting policies
based on the different types of data you
have and then also how can we evaluate
the performance of these policies how do
we know whether the you know how well
this policy works we also want to think
about you know to develop these
targeting policies we are going to use
some types of information so what is the
value of these different types of
information in particular I'm interested
in the value of contextual information
so think of this as information which
which simply relates to the when and
where so like for example which app you
are in at what time of the day and you
can think of this as broadly at like
being at the segment level so it's not
really like it's kind of
privacy-preserving right so it's not it
doesn't use any behavioral information
compared to the behavioral information
where I'm going to use all this like
tracking data so if you think about
these two pieces of information what is
the relative value of these two types of
information and once you have like but
you can double up targeting policies for
instance then you can actually get into
this question about revenue efficiency
trade-off an answer what is the
empirical relationship between
efficiency and platform revenues and is
there an optimal level of platforming a
optimal level of targeting from the
perspective of different players in
particular does an ad network have some
incentives to actually limit targeting
which means that it might at least to
some extent it might have some you know
it might want to preserve user privacy
so that's kind of the goal there if you
want to kind of get to the three answers
there are three main challenges the
first is of course that you know we want
to develop counterfactual targeting
policies which means that the ads are
being shown in a certain way in the data
we want to say no now you actually want
to allocate this ad to this this
impression so you want to think about
like you know how
factional hitting policies look like so
then we need to actually have
counterfactual click-through rate
estimates for ads which were not shown
in that impression right so not just the
ads which were shown in a given
impression if I had instead shown this
different I'd like how would people have
reacted to be able to develop an
efficient targeting policy I need to be
able to do that and in general they also
need a targeting framework with
sufficiently high predictive accuracy if
I want to be able to quantify what is
the value of different types of
information I have a very poor model you
know it's probably not going to be able
to pick up this the different you know
values correctly and finally after I can
build all these predictive models of you
know targeting I need to be able to tie
it back to revenue and that's where I'll
need an economic model of strategic
interactions right and that's
essentially some kind of an auction all
right so I need to think about how I can
tie targeting to revenues to be able to
think about market outcomes like who
gets allocated which ad and how it's the
revenue that a platform makes what's the
surplus that advertisers get and so on
so and then that will allow us to like
you know think about these questions so
platform incentives and user privacy so
here is the broad approach and I'll get
into the details of each of this as we
go through the talk at a high level what
we are going to do is think about
something like a filtering procedure for
counterfactual estimates of ads I'll
talk about the details of the auction
mechanism they're currently using but
the idea is that if we can identify you
know if there was some nonzero
probability that's a certain set of ads
could have been shown in an impression
and they have enough of those kind of
impressions then we have nonzero
propensity scores right so if I can if I
can actually identify ads in each
impression that could have been shown I
know that you know essentially any kind
of model that I built will be valid for
these counterfactual ads but not for the
rest of the counterfactual ad so so I
want to kind of build a certain
procedure for that and second for you
you then once you have those set of ads
for each impression you want to kind of
think of some kind of machine learning
predictive model
which has high predictive accuracy and
you also want to think about how you
generate features which relate to the
information that we are interested in
which is the which is like another
contextual and behavioral information to
capture what's the value of these
different pieces of information so and
for the final issue of how do you
connect these targeting policies to
revenue we are going to think of an
economic model of auctions to determine
market outcomes under counterfactual
targeting policies and what the goal
here would be to characterize
advertisers utility function in
different targeting scenarios and assume
that they are submitting bids which
maximize their you know optimal their
this you know maximize their profits and
then estimate market outcomes such as
total surplus and platform revenues
under that and then think about if the
plot since the platform is the one
designing the targeting policy and
revealing this information on targeting
to advertisers what is the optimal level
that the platform would want to stop it
and I'll try to get into the details of
each of these through the rest of the
talk so but one of the main goals here
is that you know so usually at least in
marketing and also kind of in economics
we have we have problems where people
try to make better and better
predictions with some data so they often
use predictive machine learning methods
but then often the questions end up
being prescriptive like what should some
player do so the ideal sin so here what
we're trying to do is that we want to
use tools from the you know the
predictive models but then we also want
to actually answer some kind of you know
questions which are of relevant to like
economic relevance in some ways to other
you know players and so you want to
bring in some prescriptive economic
models so the paper kind of this is a
short subset of the papers that the
areas that it relates to so it relates
like a broad you know broad areas where
such as like click-through-rate
estimation and targeting there's been a
bunch of work done on this and you know
mostly it's going to ask you
see we're going to be using boost jet
regression trees of course
methodologically it kind of relates to
papers in that area they were also being
like papers which have recently tried to
use booster regression trees for
prediction in the context of like
facebook ads and so on so relates to
that there's also like a papers more on
the advertisers side which look at this
questions related to targeting and
privacy such as if you do more targeting
our users less likely to engage with ads
and you know things like that so it
probably relates to this question of
like privacy regulation and targeting
and finally it relates to this
literature on revenue efficiency
trade-off as I said there have been a
number of papers which have been written
from a theoretical perspective on how to
do you know does more targeting actually
lead to worse efficiency and the couple
of empirical papers which kind of touch
on this topic but broadly what as I said
no one has been able to show is that
while the revenue efficiency trade-off
can possibly exist theoretically is it
going to be can we actually prove that
it's true
empirically so that's kind of the
related literature so let me move on to
the setting and data the data actually
come from a major in app advertising
platform from from a cut I usually say
large Asian country and then people
assume it's India or China out it just
me that it's like large enough but it's
neither of that I'm not supposed to
reveal the name but it's very easy to
guess if you know where oh weathers from
and what was really interesting about
this platform was that they had they
were pretty much the monopoly in that
country and had over 85 percent market
share for all the in-app ads and it was
a pretty big scale so they had they were
serving over 15 million impressions
daily and and they they had some unique
features in their advertising platform
one is that they were only showing one
format of ad now mobile ads have become
more complicated like their video ads
and like you know what they call
interstitial ads and so on so none of
that is what's happening back then at
least these guys were not using it and
they have two other features in there
setting which helped us a lot the first
chance that they were doing where they
were not doing any behavioral targeting
so they were not using all these user
IDs to do any targeting so advertisers
could only target on very broad
categories like app category like and
you know province which is like the
state or the brand of your you know
phone so it was very very broad
categories and then the platform was
running a very strange kind of auction
and the auction was essentially what it
has kind of been known in the literature
but it's not very popular in practice
this is a quasi proportional auction
which means that so usually when you
have any kind of display art setting
what people run is some kind of a you
know second price auction so quality
score intubate whoever is the highest is
going to win and they pay you know just
enough to beat the quality scoring to
bid of the next highest person right so
so that's kind of forty around but here
there were this is a this is not they
were using what you can think of as a
probabilistic allocation mechanism so
for an advertiser a the probability
they're located the ad is actually their
bidding to Quality Score / the Baron
took the summation of the variant or
quality score of everyone else and the
idea the idea is that even if you are
the most relevant ad based on your bed
into Quality Score with only some
probability you're going to be shown
with some problems you're not going to
be shown or even if you're the worst
person to be sure advertiser for this ad
but some problem you're going to be sure
so what this and the platform was not
personalizing or updating these quality
scores yeah could you clarify what a
quality score is yeah so a quality score
is something they were setting and it
was like a function of the what they
perceived you know the click-through
rate of the ad mostly the average
click-through rate of the ad in the
platform and what they thought was some
kind of like importance so these went
into like generating the quality like an
important measure of the advertiser for
them so so these were the two main
factors and they had they essentially
combined
these two and there was no real one
formula that they used and they fix
these and occasionally like every few
months or so they would revisit these
quality scores and updates them so it
was not it was not a very it was not it
was not a great way to come up with
quality scores maybe but it was
essentially taking into account the
average click-through rate of the
advertiser in the platform delivered our
pretty good ads from from good
advertisers that likely have yeah except
that that allocation mechanism kind of
like messes with that because it doesn't
always allocate to the person with the
highest burden to the Quality Score so
you know so if if my is that number is
two for me and there's only one other
competitor and that's one so it's going
to be two by two plus one so I'm going
to get it with like some too so it's
probability and so so one of the reasons
I mean we can ask them like why are you
guys doing this so there is both the
practical and kind of a theoretical
reason the practical reason was that
they were actually you know it's a
in-app advertising setting if they were
going to run any kind of deterministic
auction what would happen is that
there's going to be showing the same ad
like let's say you are paying Angry
Birds the deterministic action picks the
same ad with a didn't question score so
like all the twenty minutes that you're
playing this game and he didn't want
that so they wanted some change they
wanted to change the sequence in some
way and this was kind of a little bit of
a ad hoc way of doing it and the second
reason which they found out about later
is that there is some theory theoretical
papers on on this literature by Sigma
Rockne and various people and they show
that these kind of this kind of
allocation can sometimes give you the
best worst-case performance when
valuations are very like distributed so
in the sense that it kind of protects
you from like this exact example I was
talking about like this hundred dollars
and $1 but in general it's very bad for
Romania because you're often allocating
the ad to people who are not like the
people who value that
the most so often it's on average the
revenues would have been higher if they
were not using this mechanism but what
it does from a data generating process
perspective is that you can see that it
kind of this minimal targeting and this
kind of a quasi proportional allocation
you can think of this if you intuitively
look at the data it's as if the platform
was running a randomized experiment with
some known propensities in each strat of
the data right so it's it's it kind of
mimics that in some days if I knew the
targeting areas which are overlapping
and then I knew I set of advertisers who
are competing in that I have known
propensities in some ways so it's from
my perspective it's great because if
you're thinking about counterfactual
click-through rate estimates and
counterfactual targeting policies this
is good because it's giving us that
randomization which would not exist if
you were just working with data from
deterministic auctions so yeah in the
duration when you were looking at this
data the users population kind of fairly
stable yeah I mean if it's hungry burns
then there's a period of virality yeah
that's a good question it's a good
question yeah so this was we're going to
be using data from about like a
one-month I'll talk about the data and
the sample but we are also going to be
using data across various apps not just
one app because this is from the
platform so so they can be so I mean one
way to think about it is that these
click-through rate estimates models
would have to be retrained in time if we
expect that as some apps become more
popular or less popular people's
behavior within those apps could change
that's clearly not incentive compatible
right like you can easily have like it
and advertisers are sophisticated and
they realize then you are the amount of
bids they're putting in they're not
seeing the I mean was this actually
observed like the sort of strategic
manner yeah so so it is incentive
compatible but you know they're not
going to be bidding their valuations
yeah so it's so they're going to be
building something else we actually you
can actually show it it's shown in the
monotony paper and here as well though
our setting our payment scheme is
slightly different from theirs it's a
bit about half their valuations and you
can see that's why revenues are yeah in
the sense that so so we can invert that
from the observed date and then use that
in the second part of the paper okay
so we have data and I always get
confused as to what that number is I
guess it's 1.5 billion probably sorry
the number of zeros always confuse me
but basically they have data for about a
one-month period that's the way to think
about it and each impression basically
comes with these variables which is the
time and date stamp and the app ID the
app in which the impression happened the
device ID which is what's going to allow
us to you know you know tag these users
right at the ad ID what was the ad which
was actually shown in this impression
and targeting variables for example was
this ad targeting on you know this app
category and this province and our of
which ads which were competing in the
auction web like targeting on these
variables and the exact location the
latitude and the longitude and the most
important of course which is the click
indicator which is the outcome right so
this is the data that we have yeah
that's a good question so they have
various types of problems one is this
inadvertent clicks I'm really trying to
you know like play my day and then I
clicked on this like stupid ad by
mistake that's one problem the other
problem also is a lot of fraudulent
clicks so they have different algorithms
in place which recognizes these kind of
clicks and then reimburses advertised so
so things like you know what are like
inadvertent clicks they know if the
person bike went back so they have some
like time limits on how quickly they're
like you know like they didn't even like
you click by mistake so you're not even
come opening this ID page or like
wherever it's supposed to go you just
like went back for a fraudulent kicks
they have things like you know
various IP is I'm like you know
different like patterns so so they do
those things and they give that
indicator as well so we then throw away
those as like fake clicks but that's
what I mean that's actually I think a
bigger problem they all face like how do
you how do you actually know a clique is
a real clique and that ties to that
revenue as well because you know the
advertisers are paying for this okay so
here so here is kind of the data splits
and sampling so since we have about one
month of data and in general if you want
to understand how user B like users
history like it's going to affect their
you know behavior like you you want you
know obviously I can't take data from
like September 30th and start running
any models on that because I have no
history kind of like you know any
standard cold-start
problem so what what we are going to do
is we basically sample about 700,000
users from this period of like October
28th to October 31st which is think of
it as the last three days and then what
we do is for these users we go and pull
the entire history okay and this period
of about like 28 days I'm going to call
it kind of something like the global
data which has over 146 million
impressions and these three days I'm
going to use for training validation and
testing and so especially two days here
for training and validation and this
foot test because we don't want to use
the you know we don't we want to be able
to use the past to predict future and
like always be careful about that and uh
and we are going to use these data set
to build fear mostly the features and we
use these for like features as well like
up to the time in which it was shown so
if I'm building a feature for this
impression it's going to use all this
data as well as all the global data but
nothing in the future and then I'm going
to try then we are going to you know
build features as well as then
predictive models using that and that's
what you know the first part of the talk
kind of talks about so let me start by
defining the problem here at a very
simple level so if you have let's say
any
prescients essentially this is kind of
like you know you have a matrix which
you want to be able to have all
estimates for each cell in this matrix
so how can we estimate the click-through
rate or think of this as a match value
right which is a measure of some
relevance between the ad and the and the
impression and some people think of
these ads as like performance ads where
you want the user to take some action
rather than the ads that you see in the
front page of New York Times which are
like brand ads you just want to make you
aware of this brand exists whereas these
are more of performance apps you care
about clicks or some you know action
that the user would take so here this is
let's say you know the rows represent
impressions in your data set and the
columns represent ads and what you want
to be able to say is this like what is
m.i.a on you know for each of this cell
each of these like Searle in this matrix
that's the probability that some outcome
let's say like like is equal to 1 and
what's important to recognize is that we
are going to see the realized outcomes
for only one cell in each of these rows
right so I said I showed one ad and I'll
see 0 or 1 somewhere in one of these but
the rest I have like missing data in
some ways and I want to be able to
complete that and so we want to be able
to accurately do that and once you have
this matrix you can develop any
targeting policy that you want so I have
this matrix of what the match value
should look like I can say I want to
target targeting policy which assigns
this impression to this ad right and
essentially a targeting policy is a
mapping between impressions and ads
right so I can come up with any type of
mapping that I want to think about as
long as I know the values in the matrix
I can then understand how the targeting
policy will perform and counterfactual
situations of course the challenges are
that we want this essentially means
counterfactual click-through rate
estimation high dimensional categorical
output so if you think about the entire
sequence of history of the users think
of that as like a state space right and
that's a very large state space and
taking that and just throwing it into
any kind of predictive model is not
going to be useful so we want
be able to shrink that and we want high
predictive accuracy in terms of like you
know what we do sorry so I think that
just says okay that's the outcome that
we are interested in okay so to get the
counterfactual click-through rate
estimates because this is the task of
outcome prediction we can essentially
think about building think about using
some kind various various predictive
machine learning algorithms out there
right and them and we can do that as
long as our data actually not nothing to
do with algorithm the data satisfy some
properties which is the same as long as
the Joint Distribution of covariates
when outcomes in my training data and
test data contractual data is the same
which is this thing here I'm able I'm
going to be able to predict my prey a
counterfactual predictions are going to
be correct or the other way to kind of
think about this is that estimates are
accurate as long as I could have been
shown in an impression which means that
this is this you know in the standard
statistics literature this would
otherwise be called the overlap
assumption or nonzero propensity score
assumption so for ads which have nonzero
propensity score I can actually you know
if I ran some machine learning model to
learn from it and then predicted on
those ads as long as I have sufficiently
large data set and you know then I can
you know call consistency and say that
you know in in this case this
counterfactual prediction would have
been accurate so of course the key
requirement as we all know here is
randomization and this is where this
limited targeting provision and this
probabilistic allocation helps right if
it was deterministic allocation the same
I would have been shown in a type of an
impression because now it's
probabilistic you're going to see a
broad set of apps and ads a broad set of
eyes shown in a same type of an
impression and that's going to help you
you know with this counterfactual
prediction but there are still acts
which are not shown in certain
impressions for example some advertisers
might say that they don't want their ads
to be targeted let's say in Washington
right then for those ads I'm not going
to be able to
at least like accurately predict the
click-through rate for you know people
in Washington State
so what we do is you what we want to do
intuitively is identify the availab so
we're going to use the first ring
procedure and the first ring is again
think of it as a matrix for each
impression and each row here so for each
impression it for each row
think about let's say these two ads
could have never been shown I want to
call them zero so it's a matrix of zeros
and ones I want to identify for a name
for an impression for a row which ads
could have been shown they become once
and which ads could have been zero then
I can do a you know like I'm dot product
of these so so intuitively how do we do
that we look at the targeting decision
so we see where they are targeting and
whether this impression falls under the
targeting area and the other way in
which ads become aware and available is
like budget exhaustion which means that
they ran their ad and their budget is
exhausted so you know from 9 p.m. to 12
in the night they're not gonna be
showing any at so for those so we we
take that into account so we filter out
ads which are not available for a given
impression and you're going to call this
the filtered sample and here is actually
a distribution of the number of ads
available for each impression you know
the and you can see that so this is for
shown for the top 37 ads which kind of
constitute over 30% of the traffic in
the data and you can see that about like
the median impression has at least like
10 advertisers competing on it yeah
cross-check this filtering procedure
with ground truth from the ad platform
it so clearly they had some logging when
the impressions were actually happening
so they must have defined their softmax
probability over a set of candidate and
right so we would know immediately like
so the filter for the targeting we know
that you know from that is from the
platform like this ad was the budget
exhaustion is inferred
the way this was inferred was that if
I'd was being shown in this thing and
then over this entire targeting like
yeah because probabilistically over the
sufficiently large number of impressions
they should like only at least one
occurrence of the ad should have
happened and if that occurrence is 0
then we infer that okay this ad is
somehow not competing in that in that
thing but that's a good idea
I don't think no B we could not do that
I mean we were like a couple of reasons
for that
a the team we were working with was more
of like you know in the like they were
not right in part of this and eventually
by the time they put us in touch with
and so on these guys got acquired by a
different then you know that was like
again like you know who had in ground
zero again like we starting like all
this but that's a good idea because it
should have been in their code as to
what is who are the people competing in
the auction and that I mean you don't
have to infrared you you know they
should know have seen is like it seems
easy to write down that hey these are
the probabilities I just block them to
be a bunch of yeah yeah because if the
data is small let's say the targeting
area is kind of small the observer zero
probability and that is kind of like an
observed zero probability is still a
probability where we can't predict like
in that sample so from a production
perspective it's fine but in theory it
might be a nonzero probability even if
the observed probability is zero but
that's a good idea we should see if we
can somehow like track them down again
okay so so you know so we do see
sufficient actually there I had a slide
on randomization I took that out like
you know showing some data on that but
in the interest of time but you know
this is the feature generation framework
so we have all these like high
dimensional inputs categorical inputs
like the user app add and time and so on
and what I
what you want to do is you want the
kindness this is something I've done in
a previous paper as well but you want to
come up with functions that map these
like very high-dimensional categorical
inputs into some meaningful features
using both like user level and global
history and intuitively if you think
about it what we want to capture is like
features which are related to three
types of information right one is the
contextual information the when and
where of the data so for example if you
have you wanna you want to know or
intuitively we know that people's
behavior or response to ads and like a
gaming app is going to be different than
let's say Craigslist app or time of day
let's say you're at work at 10:00 a.m.
like you know unless you're at like 8:00
p.m. also related to behavioral related
to the user's past app usage ad exposure
and AD response and AD related maybe
some ads are just like you know from
more high reputation firms just better
designed and you know people are more
likely to respond to them compared to
others so you know so we make features
related to these and you know just to
give you an example of for example an ad
related feature would be something like
what is the click-through rate of this
ad on the global data in this app at
this time of the day so that's one or it
could be what's the global what's the
click-through rate of this ad isn't this
our overall time service a so you know
many many different features like this
similarly for this user in a given app
for a given ad combination you could
also combine it for time so you can see
they're all these like different
permutations and combinations so we
basically define a lot of functions
which do that because you don't want to
define each feature individually that's
just going to be like you know functions
are more parsimonious and we also define
them over these features over different
types of histories over the entire one
month also over like shorter because as
you were saying you know as the app
becomes more or less popular
maybe behavior changes and that might be
useful to know over the last week or
even within the session right like
within the session you know if you were
behaving in a certain way maybe that has
some information and that gives us about
like 1/6 a features and you can actually
categorize them as behavioral features
contextual features and add specific
features and
obviously there's a big overlapping area
because if a feature captures
information on both user behavior as
well as the context then it's both
behavioral and contextual if it captures
only behavior like what is the average
click-through rate of this user with a
you know globally like without like
information on app or time it's going to
be purely behavioral so this is the set
of features VQ so think of this is it
kind of like explanation variables of
covariates and then we want to throw it
into some kind of like a learning
algorithm to predict click-through rate
and we're going to use log loss as our
objective function it has good
properties like you know fast
convergence and it's pretty commonly
used and click-through rate prediction
and the idea is that we have some
observed data for which we know the wire
is right the outcome 0 or 1 then in
impression I some ad was shown let's say
the I which was shown was AI and we want
to get these M hats which is our
predicted click-through rates when we
when we do this and of course we are
going to do some validation we are going
to have you know holdout validation we
have enough data we don't have to do
cross validation and the learning
algorithm B actually uses XG boost which
I think pretty much many of you are
familiar with so it actually was
developed at in argued of cs department
which i found out afterwards and and
it's a fast and scalable version of
course it has been very successful in
many many settings and it generally
works much better than any other
learning algorithm that we could use
yeah assumptions being made to assert
the validity of this counterfactual CTR
prediction because I wouldn't ask you
think if I'm thinking about different
targeting policy that's probably sending
things differently that actually gets
reflected in the X features that you are
constructing you're thinking about like
the previous on exposure so that's a
good point so in some ways as long as
you okay so the assumption would be that
if you think of this as a short-term
counterfactual a long-term contractual
value change targeting policies is also
going to
like the distribution of exes right and
and then if there is overlap between
that distribution of X and this
distribution of X we are still okay but
if the overlap between that distribution
of new distribution of X which are
targeting policy my generation and our
existing distribution of X then we have
problem again yeah we will need to
correct for it again using this I mean
as long as there's overlap we have a way
out yeah but if there is no overlap yeah
in theory we have a way out at least but
if there is no overlap or very little
overlap then we are going to have a
problem and that is why when you have I
mean the other so I feel like certain
types of features we are actually will
be fine with and in to the extent that
for example app usage is not highly
correlated based with targeting policy
so the way I play Angry Birds and
respond to you know you know and how
often I come back and you know how long
how long my session is and so on it's
not very highly correlated with ad
response to the hum extent that's okay
so you will see some overlap but if
there are features which are very highly
but that might also that's a good
question I should think yeah so if
you're showing an ad more and that you
are showing it to in better settings and
therefore it's getting better clicks
then you know you have suddenly more
date or more accuracy in that and
therefore you might it might behave and
so so anything that you so that's
actually a limitation in some ways in
the sense that we treat these more as
like short term contractual rather than
long-term contractual but the right way
to do this would be like basically to we
simulate the system with a new but then
we would also need assumptions on how
the user would behave or like basically
run an experiment that's a good yeah but
that's a that's a fair point okay so how
do you evaluate this model there are two
ways to essentially evaluate this the
first
is you know there's you know standard
measures of fit that when you run some
kind of a predictive model you have some
measure of like how well you predict it
and you have the outcome right and and
then you can't you know one commonly
used measure is like relative log loss I
mean one thing in these click prediction
models which many of you might have
noticed is that of course you know there
is a 99.9 percent probability no one
clicks on anything like even if I just
went there and said no one ever clicks
on anything I have a pretty good model
right or just like an average prediction
so what this is doing is basically
taking the log loss of like an average
prediction like if I just predicted
average for everyone without a model and
how much will my model which is like you
know some kind of like I am hat like any
model that you can throw in how much
better is it going to do that's kind of
like you know define us or relative
information gain of your model over like
you know what I can just like get from
the average in the data so what we are
what and what this is really using is
actually it's losing factual data so
this model evaluation is just using
factual data so the red elements are
actually in each of this like rows are
the ads which were actually shown so
it's looking it's basically making a
prediction for these ends like some kind
of M hat and it has zeros and ones from
the data on whether you know and you see
how close this M hat and this and the
true Y's are so that's what we are doing
and and it's it's good in many ways as I
said it's consistent with the loss
function because it uses log loss as the
input and you can you know use other
evaluation metrics if you want but the
basic idea is that on one way to do
model evaluation is to see how well your
model predicts on the data which was
kind of shown the second way to do a
model evaluation is to think about what
is the potential improve we how well
your model does is that if you use this
model to allocate ads right efficiently
instead of the ad which was shown how
much better would how what is the
improvement in click-through rate that
you would see okay so so this is based
on counterfactual outcome so now let's
say that the ad which was shown in the
data was actually the right ad for this
impression but let's suppose that
actually our
says that the I highest is actually for
this ad here so highest M height as for
this I and they showed this ad now
instead of the red and what is the
improvement and click-through rate that
we would see so in some ways let's say
if you use we call this the efficient
targeting policy in the sense that
you're allocating each impression to the
best ad that would work for this ad and
and then you know this is another way to
evaluate the model so let me actually
show you results from both of these so
the first is on our IG and the value of
information so we run different types of
model when we want to calculate our IG
in one we just run a contextual model
with like ad specific features where you
don't use any behavioral information in
the second we use only behavioral
information and you know add specific
features and finally we use everything
so as you can see you know they're just
using behavioral information behavioral
model does much much better than
contextual model so even if I don't use
any contextual information related to a
poor time or anything just knowing what
someone did without any context is
actually more powerful than using like
lot of contextual information of course
if I use both I do much much better that
should be expected but what it kind of
says is that behavioral information you
know just so if you are just thinking
about efficient targeting behavioral
information is more valuable it's of
course not great for user privacy from a
privacy perspective but it also improves
targeting so one thing is that more and
more targeting using behavioral
information is better sorry
so here is the part on the
counterfactual click-through rate
improvement here we are just actually
allocating adds to the best ad in the
you know like I said which was predicted
and I'm showing you the percentage you
know click-through rate improvements for
different types of live for all the
impressions is the distribution and this
0 here in the beginning or this one here
in the beginning essentially refers to
ads which were which actually ended up
because it's probabilistic probably
strictly getting the best ad which was
also you know the ad which was the best
for it I mean
other way to evaluate this and we didn't
have space and the paper is like very
long already is to use IP w.zahn that to
just like you know okay this is the this
is where like you know you have these
policy congruent observations and once
you put in IP WS then you're just going
to get you can scale up if I if I
actually use this evaluation and that's
about we did that and that's about the
same as like the 66% okay so this so
what we have shown so far is that okay
you can actually use different targeting
methods especially behavioral targeting
and improve you know targeting
efficiency quite a bit now let's think
about this question of okay this revenue
efficiency trade-off how many how much
time do I have
out okay sounds good
yeah that should be more than enough so
this is a this is something that we you
know talked about earlier I gave you
some intuition for that this is an
example which kind of like explains that
intuition in a much simpler way so let's
say we have two advertisers one for an
airline and one for one for you know
some kind of a gym and there are two
users a traveler and this lady who's
working out at the gym so for this
airline ad let's say this ivory tiser is
worth about five dollars for this you
know this add to that for the gym this
this user is about worth about $1 okay
is that clear what these and then
whereas the opposite is kind pattern is
true for this lady so now if the
advertiser yeah what is five dollars
versus one the valuation for the click
so if I got a click from this year then
what would be the value of that for me
okay so they're getting a surplus ten
dollars yeah at this point we haven't
gotten to the surplus these now these
like squares and these crosses just
indicate let's say indicate valuations
for now okay okay so this is your
hypothetical this is an example yeah
okay yeah okay okay so let's say this is
what is happening and now let's say the
address the platform is allowed is
revealing who is who in some ways and
allowing you to do this targeting right
at an individual level then of course in
a second track this is the setting of a
standard second price auction right so
here this airplane this travel
advertiser is going to bid five dollars
on this guy and the other this gem is
going to paid $1 right so this person is
going to win the ad but going to pay $1
is that clear so this is what's
happening in same thing kind of opposite
so you can see that now their revenue
for the platform is $2 here okay so it's
efficient in the sense the ad shown
being shown to each user is relevant the
total surplus created in the system is
pretty high right but it's actually not
good from the platform's perspective
they make $2 but now let's say the
platform bundles these two impressions
and doesn't allow advertisers to
distinguish them okay I don't reveal who
is who then they're going to bed both an
average number right so the the because
the airline advertiser have an average
valuation which is kind of higher for
both they're going to bed about $3 which
is the average of Phi 1 1 right and this
other advertiser is going to bed about
for $2 all right is that clear to
everyone and then again in a second
price auction this airline advertiser is
going to get both these impressions okay
and but they're going to pay $2 for each
impression all right so the platform now
makes $4 even though the overall surplus
which is being generated in the system
is lower yes here is if there's going to
be more more competition for bidding
when there's less bundling or when
there's less I should say when there's
less granular so the infusion is that
more efficiency in the system more
targeting always increases increases
surplus that you create but it does not
translate to revenues always so this is
an example which shows that revenue and
efficiency can go in the opposite
direction
yes question earlier so the Assumption
here we have just talked about the
valuation of the gin lady for that in
isolation
I wonder should she have like a negative
valuation for the ad thing or for the
airplane ad because the moment we is
cynic actually in that bundle thing
there are a whole bunch of 811 ads being
shown to a whole bunch of people and
there is a cost to that it says that
you're assuming that cost away yeah so
if in this case you're kind of saying
that we are looking at this more from
the perspective of the advertiser and
the platform if the user has some kind
of like negative externality and that
affects usage for example usage of the
platform or something then that would
have to be taken into account so am i
saying and and that's a question that's
kind of an empirical question and what
is the if I show a relevant ad or you
know and and there are some people's
which have looked at this empirically
there they show there is kind of a sweet
spot if it's to targeted people find it
creepy if it's not at all targeted
they're also like you know don't love it
so but that's kind of an empirical
question of like but that has to come
through the user level usage model but
in an auction for an impression this is
still kind of going to have to be true
from advertisers perspective yes is it
maybe good analogy to say that you're
upselling to the advertiser is
essentially users that you wouldn't want
to pay for really and that much you kind
of bubbling them together in that way so
no that would be more like some kind of
an adverse selection so here all we are
saying is that like you so essentially
this is this this this dotted area here
is what we call the information trend
so usually advertisers valuations are
private to them right and the more so
any any kind of efficient contracting
this is I'm talking about a second price
auction but you know in general based on
this revenue equivalence principle any
efficient auction mechanism will have
the same same result in some ways which
is kind of remarkable in that way so
what this essentially says is that when
you are able to target better and better
advertisers gain more information like
informational knowledge and because that
is that you know private information
they can actually extract the surplus so
it's like an information asymmetry more
than anything else so so that's kind of
the intuition so the question is what's
the optimal level of targeting from the
perspective yeah
what in this reasoning here but do you
have to assume that or do you assume
that the targeting is mutually exclusive
that like if that that the exercising
person here is not also yeah you have to
adapt or something else or oh no so
either I'll talk about the model in a
moment so and how we kind of okay so
here is in the interest of time I'm
going to make this short so you can
again go back to this like matrix way of
thinking we were we had which is that so
this is the advertisers value for each
impression right let's say and you can
think of Tatia
everyone in the room can just sit it on
tilt well then we can just take over the
remaining 15 minutes of the are to just
push back yeah understand it okay is
that fine absolutely okay so okay okay
so we looked right I try to make it
short but hopefully follow so in general
the way you think about a targeting here
is like think of targeting is like
bundling of impressions right so if I if
the advertisers can distinguish each
impression they bundles like a bundle of
one if I don't give you any information
and say like everyone in this platform I
don't tell you anything about anyone in
this then it's a bundle of one okay so
but basically like platforms are so
essentially you can think of targeting
as like a bundling strategy how do you
bundle this and you can then formally we
actually define this granularity of
targeting levels and the idea is that if
if so any any targeting strategy is
basically a definition of funders and
then tag a bundle is basically like one
targeting strategy is more granular than
the other if two impressions which are
distinguishable in one also continue to
be distinguishable and the other so you
can actually prove this theoretically
that's what kind of really cool about
this without making any functional form
assumptions on the valuations we show
theoretically that as the granularity of
targeting increases then the total
surplus or efficiency is going to
increase you can actually prove this so
that as you target
targeting criminals increases
monotonically surplus increases but we
actually can't sign the platform
revenues which means that we can't show
theoretically the platform revenues are
increasing or decreasing so that's kind
of an empirical question so that's why
we then basically go and build for
targeting policies which is one is no
targeting so there's no targeted bidding
okay the second is contextual targeting
which means that apps like advertisers
know the app and ad level like you know
click-through rate okay so which is like
I think of all apps and times as one
bundles and behavioral targeting they
can target at the user level so they
know who the user is but not what the
context is and finally they can target
on everything at the impression level
and we then based on that proposition we
show that the surplus for full targeting
is greater than that for like contextual
and behavioral remember one is not more
granular than the other because we can't
like you know sign them and then on plat
on platform revenues we don't have any
theoretical guarantees so so essentially
now the question is how do we estimate
this the only key intuition here which I
want to add more than before is that
there is this quick valuation of the
advertiser in a you know when you change
the targeting strategy they're going to
change their bids based on a valuation
and there is still the match value which
we had estimated in the previous part of
the paper right so you want to
essentially resolve for people's
equilibrium bidding strategies under
different targeting scenarios as long as
we know this we should be able to do
that and we then go and actually
estimate the click valuation of
advertisers based on this quasi
proportional auction that we observe in
the data and there's the general like
large literature on estimating auctions
but the main idea is that if you observe
the equilibrium paid and you know the
allocation rule which is used you can
actually invert to the evaluation from
that okay based on what is we observe
from the data and so here is a okay this
is not very necessary but here are the
results so the main results are that as
you can see going from no targeting to
full targeting this is like you know
like normalize numbers so they don't
have any meaning but you can see that
the total surplus
increasing but if you look at platform
revenues they are the highest for
contextual targeting so when the
platform does not use behavioral
targeting they actually are better off
in terms of revenues compared to
contextual yes doesn't it strikes me
that what matters is the cross of the
valuation of the marginal bidders that
are taken out as you get more granular
is that right and so effectively what
this is saying is that the marginal
valuation of remaining bidders is higher
in the contextual case than for the
behavioral case so they're all there so
we are not changing the set of bidders
in any auction but what is happening is
that the information rank that you are
paying the winning bidder is lower in
the contextual case than in the in the
behavioral right so anyway so the main
idea is that you can actually tie it
back to the privacy question we talked
about earlier right which is that when
you have where so the platform has some
natural incentives to maybe limit
targeting maybe not to you know fully
like eliminate behavioral targeting but
it seems like the platform's incentives
and consumers incentives are to some
extent at least aligned so to conclude
basically the paper has you know
contributions both from methodological
and substantive areas one is that we
kind of provide this scalable machine
learning framework for targeting that's
compatible for counterfactual analysis
of functions in a competitive
environment and importantly from a
policy perspective we show that
advertising platforms do have incentives
to self-regulate and you know there
might be something to that as like
regulators are talking about you know to
what extent should they actually be like
regulating ad industry that's pretty
much it and qualities for running over
time